hey this is presh talwalkar
here's an email i received
i really like your youtube videos and i
wanted to send you one of my favorite
riddles
in my opinion it is somewhat hard but
the solution is very cool
alice and bob are playing a game using a
chessboard
this is an 8x8 grid
alice starts by placing a knight on the
board
then they take turns moving the knight
to a new square one that it has not been
on before
standard chest rules apply the knight
can only move in an l shape that's two
squares in one direction and one square
to the side
this is one possible place the knight
could go and these are all the other
places the knight could go from the
original square
each time the knight moves it has to
move in this l shape
the first player who cannot move the
knight to a new square loses the game
who wins if both players play optimally
and what is the winning strategy
so i'll admit this problem stumped me
and i could not figure it out
i want to thank sebastian for suggesting
this problem and for sending me the
solution
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so before i get to the solution i want
to mention this problem is an example of
game theory a mathematical field where
you solve games of strategic interaction
alice's best move depends on what she
thinks bob will do and bob's best move
will depend on what alice did and might
do each person is trying to outsmart the
other like a cat in mouse chase
remarkably we can analyze these
situations and actually find solutions
for some games
in this game we can prove bob can always
win no matter how alice plays
how can we do that we will use an
interesting concept called a graph
coloring proof
so let's prove that bob can always win
this game
we start out with our chessboard and
we're going to divide it into eight
different four by two regions
so one two three four five six seven and
eight
so what's so important about these
well let's analyze one of them in
particular
suppose the knight is in one of these
squares
where could the knight go while staying
in the same 4x2 region
this is the key to the whole problem
from a square in a given four by two
region a knight has only one legal move
to stay in the same four by two region
so from this square there's only one
possible spot the knight could go while
staying in this four by two region
so what we'll do is we'll color code
these two squares the same color
so from either of these squares the
knight can only move to the other
position
this will be true for every single
square in this four by two region for
example from the lower right hand square
there's only one possible place the
knight could go from there and vice
versa
so we'll color these two the same color
we can do it for the remaining squares
in this four by two region
we'll mark two squares the same color if
the knight can move between them
now what can this coloring do
well it'll apply to every single one of
these four by two regions
so from a given four by two region we
know there's only one legal move to stay
in that same four by two region
so how does this help bob win the game
alice starts the game by placing the
knight in some four by two region
let's say she places the knight here
what bob will do is he'll then move the
knight to the only other legal square in
the same 4x2 region
now the key is that bob has taken the
only other legal square in that 4x2
region
this forces alice to move the knight to
a new 4x2 region on her next move she
cannot stay within the same 4x2 region
because these two squares have already
been visited so let's say alice moves
here
now where should bob move
well he's then going to move the knight
to the only other legal square in that
four by two region
he applies the same coloring pattern to
that region
in this case the knight is on a yellow
square
so bob is going to move to the other
yellow square
as long as bob continues this strategy
he will always have a move and he forces
alice into finding a new 4x2 region on
every single move
alice has to keep finding new squares in
different 4x2 regions and eventually she
will not find one the game has to end in
65 moves or fewer as there are a total
of 64 squares
therefore bob can always win this game
and like magic we've solved this problem
and shown that bob can always win
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel and make videos
on math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic suggestion you can email me
presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at
mindyourdecisions or at presh talwalkar